have you ever wondered which Disney
Princesses would be besties we've had a
lot of fun carrying them up
keep watching to the end to discover the
adorable real-life link between two of
the princesses the actors fed voiced
Ariel knows which princess her girl
would be besties with we could not
contain our excitement when all the
Disney Princesses came together and
Ralph breaks the Internet we saw them in
their casual clothes bonding over their
shared experiences and we started to
imagine which princesses would be most
likely to pair up as BFFs
we've analyzed their character traits
and dissected what they were like in
their movies to come up with our list of
Disney princess besties as you watch
along be sure to tell us if you agree
I'm guessing you don't have much
experience with heat nope first up its
Snow White and Cinderella we're starting
at the very beginning with the very
first ever Disney Princess Snow White
she got the whole franchise rolling in
1937 and ushered in the Golden Age of
Disney Princesses this era includes
Cinderella and Aurora - the heroines of
these three movies in the 1930s and
1950s have lots in common they all wait
passively for their prince to arrive
they all look and act the same being
dainty and ladylike and they all have to
face the same nemesis a villainous older
woman their tails are a straightforward
battle of good versus bad so we think
Snow White and Cinderella would
definitely get each other these two more
so than Aurora have a heap of shared
interests they both love to hang with
animals and they both spend a lot of
time cleaning we can just imagine Snow
White and Cinderella hanging out
together in our modern-day world they'd
watch Marie Kondo on Netflix and obsess
over how to fold clothes they'd work
together in an animal sanctuary and
they'd constantly take lost causes and
strays back home to their spotlessly
clean apartments when they weren't
cleaning and baking homemade cookies
they'd be out singing in their local
choir sure all the Disney Princesses
love to sing but you can imagine that
these two actually consider singing to
be a serious hobby after all they didn't
do much else in their films other than
clean sing and wait all of that would
only be practical if they were quite a
bit older than they were in their movies
why so you might be shocked when we
reveal Snow White's actual age fun fact
Snow White is only 14 so whether or not
she's
the fairest of them all she's certainly
the youngest of them all ready for
another fun fact Cinderella was Walt
Disney's favorite heroine he told the
actress that voiced Cinderella but there
was something about the story that he
could really associate with Aurora might
be feeling a little left out but we've
got a different Betty mind up for her
Aurora and Rapunzel Aurora exhibits all
those same characteristics as the other
Golden Age princesses but we reckon
she'd get on perfectly with a more
modern princess and that's Rapunzel
although there's more than 50 years
between their films Aurora and Rapunzel
have a lot in common
they're both dreamers and they both have
a love story at the heart of their
movies even though Rapunzel is part of
the revival era of Disney Princesses
there are aspects of her story that hark
back to the Golden Age era sure she's
more independent and proactive she hits
Flynn with a frying pan and takes charge
and she's pretty darn sassy - but
Rapunzel didn't go on her own journey by
herself she needed Flynn to help her
escape the tower and track down the
lanterns and the 2010 movie wound up
with the Golden Age happy ending of a
wedding but the dynamic in tangled was
different it wasn't totally one-sided
with the man as the hero Rapunzel and
Flynn saved each other Aurora on the
other hand did totally rely on Prince
Phillip to show up and save her however
she had a dream that she was totally
committed to and that shows a certain
amount of strong-willed spirit just like
Rapunzel had a dream that she wouldn't
give up they both even have songs about
dreams for goodness sake we can just
imagine these two besties doodling love
hearts and lanterns all over their
notebooks in their poetry class because
they would totally be taking night
classes together at their local
community college Rapunzel would love
helping her BFF learn how to paint and
Aurora would teach her bestie how to
forage for berries they would also bond
over their upbringing although both of
their moms were alive which is rare for
a Disney Princess neither of them were
raised by their birth mothers we could
also see Rapunzel being good friends
with Anna from frozen their votes super
enthusiastic and go-getters but we've
picked someone else to be honest besties
based on something that only the two of
them have in common in the Disney
princess world stay tuned for that later
as we're moving on to Ana's sister now
jasmine and
although Elsa and Anna would of course
have a bond that could never be broken
we don't actually envisage the sisters
being besties instead we reckon Elsa
would love hanging out with Jasmine's
the princess from Aladdin is as much of
a rebel as frozen's ice queen although
there's more than 20 years between
Jasmine's 1992 movie and Elsa's 2013
film they have plenty in common they
both want to break free from the
confines placed on them and they're both
proactive in seeking a new life for
themselves given Jasmine's skill and
hopping over castle walls we can just
picture her sneaking into private
parties and Elsa would be totally on
board with her BFF acting all haughty
if anyone accused them of gate-crashing
these two would certainly get up to a
lot of mischief together we also think
jasmine would be good friends with Ariel
they bond over their shared experience
of defying their fathers and running
away they're both part of the
Renaissance era of Disney Princess
movies this era includes Belle Mulan and
Pocahontas - and these princesses are
more progressive and independent than
the Golden Age trio that came before
them these ladies aren't waiting around
for a prince to save them or doing what
their father's tell them to do speaking
of which let's move on to another
renaissance girl now Pocahontas and Anna
at first glance this pairing might seem
a little surprising but when you go deep
with these two you'll see that they
actually have a lot in common and where
it matters most in their hearts and
souls they both have the superpower of
love and they're both willing to make
the ultimate sacrifice that's going to
bond you tight as besties it would be
too tiresome for either of these ladies
to be BFFs with someone who is too
preoccupied with their own stuff to care
about others we can just imagine him
going on marches and protests together
of the peaceful kind naturally
Pocahontas is a pacifist after all in
her 1995 film Pocahontas was willing to
sacrifice her life to save Jon but it
wasn't just about romantic love it was
also about her deep love for her village
and for the earth in her 2013 movie Anna
was also willing to sacrifice herself
for love it was to save her sister
rather than her lover and that shows how
important love of all kinds is to both
of these princesses the romantic love is
another interesting thing they have in
common specifically they both have two
interests in their films this sets them
apart from all of their Disney
Princesses and we can just imagine these
besties having late-night video chats
about their relationship dramas we can
also imagine Pocahontas being good
friends with Moana after all these two
both love nature but we paired up Moana
with someone who's totally on her level
in a different way
Merida and Moana first up let us say
that we love both Merida and Moana
they're feisty and strong-willed and are
totally inspiration in the way they
fight against what's expected of them
however they both have a touch of the
silky teenager about them particularly
Merida but we're not judging we totally
get why they would want to rage against
their parents they're ready to get on
with life on their own terms and they
don't want to be held back by their
parents limiting expectations for them
they want to break free from their
confined roles and they're not bothered
about doing what they're told this is
exactly why they would bond and become
besties we can just imagine them helping
each other out when their folks are
being overbearing if one of them got
grounded the other would totally hatch a
plan they'd be constructing all kinds of
devices to help their BFF sneak out we
could see these two going on an amazing
gap year together before they head it to
college Moana could steer the boat and
Merida could catch fish with her bare
hands we could also see Merida being
good friends with Mulan Merida would
look up to the warrior princess and
respect her fighting skills they love
sparring together and going on survival
weekends but we think Mulan would
actually be BFFs with the princess who
shares her dedication and work ethic
doesn't give you power to create life
it's a homing beacon of death Tiana and
Mulan Tiana has the distinction of being
the only Disney princess with a
full-time job in fact she works more
than one job so to say she's a hard
worker is somewhat of an understatement
and you know who else works incredibly
hard Mulan that too she's trained
tirelessly to become the best soldier
and you know save her entire country no
biggie
so these two besties would have a lot of
respect for one another
they'd never find themselves in a
situation where one had to drag the
other up to her level
they'd meet up before work each morning
and get an early gym session in Tiana
and Mulan would also bond over their
love and respect for their fathers even
though Mulan defied her father by
joining the army she was doing it to
protect him Mulan was doing it out of
love for
and that's in contrast to the other
princesses in the Renaissance era tiana
worked tirelessly to open her own
restaurant out of respect for her father
but she eventually realized that her dad
was trying to teach her about the
importance of love above all else that's
a lesson that Mulan learned too we could
imagine Tiana and Milan being good
friends with Val - Belle also has a deep
love and respect for her father and she
sacrifices herself to take his place in
the beasts dungeon these three give us
good daughter goals but we actually
picked out a different princess to be
Belle's BFF and that's because of a very
special real-life reason Ariel and
though our final pair of Disney Princess
besties have their very own cheerleader
and that's Jodi Benson Jodi is the
original voice of Ariel in the 1989
movie so she should know a thing or two
about the Little Mermaid and she's
revealed which princess she thinks Ariel
would be BFFs with and that's Belle Jodi
made the revelation in an interview in
2019 celebrating 30 years since the
movie came out and she explained her
sweet reasoning behind her choice it's
because the woman who voices Belle page
O'Hara is one of Jodi's oldest and
dearest friends they've been friends for
over 36 years so because the two voice
actresses have a great friendship
Jodi thinks that Ariel and Belle would
follow suit she believes that the
princesses would connect with each other
in so many different ways
Ariel loves think of a-bombs and books
and everything that Belle's involved
with so she thinks they'd be best
friends because they're best friends in
life believe it or not there's another
real-life reason why these two
princesses are linked Sherri stoner was
the live-action model for both Ariel and
spell so they're connected in lots of
ways we could just imagine Ariel and Val
being part of a book club and getting
excited about the latest releases so
there you have it our take on which
Disney Princesses would be besties did
we get it right which Disney Princess
would you want as your BFF weighed in
your opinion in the comments section
below thanks for watching make sure to
subscribe to the things for more videos
like this one and don't forget to give
this video a big thumbs up we'll see you
next time
[Music]